it's just gone 1500 GMT and UK and EU
leaders have finalized a new deal for
Northern Ireland's post-brexit trading
Arrangements European commission
president Ursula vandelayan has been
meeting prime minister of the UK Rishi
sunak to discuss the details of the
Northern Ireland protocol now disputes
over the deal have prevented a
government from forming in Northern
Ireland we've got correspondence
covering both sides of this story we
have Rory challenge in Northern Ireland
in Belfast but first let's go over to
Jonah Hull in Westminster so Jonah
finally a deal has been struck what do
we know about the details in it
but it's extraordinary isn't it to still
be here talking about brexit talking
about striking brexit deals when brexit
was supposed to have been done quite
some time ago the reality is it was
never done and it was never going to be
done until this issue of Northern
Ireland was resolved the internal
contradiction in the entire process
whereby the UK leaves the EU
necessitating a new trade border between
the two that border can't run across the
island of Ireland because of the Good
Friday peace agreement and so Boris
Johnson in 2020 signs a deal putting
that trade Border in the Irish sea
rejected eventually of course by the
Democratic unionist who saw it as
undermining Northern Ireland's place in
the union of the United Kingdom and them
boycotting power sharing as a result and
so the need for the UK to negotiate for
weeks and weeks and weeks now for
concessions from the EU which they
appear now to have got they haven't
scrapped the protocol this is an update
to the north Northern Ireland Protocol
New Provisions that will run alongside
it that will ease the passage of trade
let me say we haven't seen the text of
the deal yet but leaks indicate that it
will ease the passage of trade from the
United Kingdom Mainland into Northern
Ireland for goods not destined to go any
further than that that it is hope will
lessen or minimize any potential role
for the European court of justice that
was a big problem for the parties uh in
being final Arbiter to any disputes and
Northern Ireland It is believed will be
given the final say in any new rules
that are developed over time within the
eu's single market for goods that would
eventually apply to them the so-called
Democratic deficit that the Democratic
unionists in Northern Ireland were so
worried about that seems to be the shape
and function of these new Provisions to
the deal the big question is for Rishi
sunach the Prime Minister who has really
stuck his neck out here it's a big
gamble for him a huge political moment
in his Premiership is whether that deal
is acceptable to the Democratic
unionists whether they feel that it
solves their Democratic deficit that it
puts them back in essential alignment
with the rest of the United Kingdom and
whether he can square it with his own
MPS on the right of his party who have
already voiced concern that any deal
that continues to exert EU influence on
the Affairs of Northern Ireland and
therefore the UK could yet be struck
down well that's going to be interesting
in the coming hours isn't it because
Russia sunak will be addressing
parliament in a few hours after he gets
a press conference with Ursula vandelier
which we will bring to our viewers live
when that happens we believe in the next
hour so after that he will be where you
are in Westminster talking about this
deal taking it to Parliament will there
be a parliamentary vote on it
we haven't heard any final conclusion on
that there certainly is pressure on
number 10 Downing Street to offer a vote
initially there was reluctance by Rishi
sunak's team for quite obvious reasons
because there was concern about a
backlash amongst his own MPS he didn't
want it to go to a vote because that
might only serve to highlight new deep
divisions within his party he won't lose
a vote because the labor party has
already said they would support a deal
if a deal is reached but he would want
to avoid the Optics of division in the
party uh so the question is does the dup
accept this deal if they do MPS in his
party are likely to fall into line we
all await they await the legal text of
the deal so that that could be very
carefully scrutinized it does now sound
likely that Downing Street will in fact
Grant a vote a vote as I say that they
will win but they will hope not to have
to win it by exposing new divisions in
the party okay Jonah Holt for the moment
thanks very much we will come back to as
we get more details about the text of
this deal and of course as we hear from
the UK prime minister in the coming
hours let's go over now to Northern
Ireland and speak to Roy challenge he's
live for us in Belfast as we heard Jonas
saying there Rory key to this deal is
whether or not the dup Northern
Ireland's unius whether they will accept
it they're going to be examining it very
closely aren't they what are they most
concerned about
they are going to be going through it
line by line they say they have the
lawyers ready and they will be pouring
over every aspect of this deal they do
not want to let anything slip through
they don't want to make any mistakes
that could come back and bite them so it
could take some time for the dep to come
to a settled position on what this deal
is and whether they can give it their
green lights they of course hate the
Northern Ireland protocol it is the
reason why this building behind me has
not seen really any political activity
for months because the dup pulled out of
the power sharing agreement part of the
Good Friday peace deal that ended the
northern Northern Ireland travels many
many years ago
that's political paralysis has been
ongoing for months now since the dup in
protest at the Northern Ireland protocol
pulled out and said we're not doing any
business until that protocol is amended
or sorted so what they want to see
essentially is the role of Europe and
the European Union taken out as much as
possible
from northern Ireland's Affairs they
talk about this Democratic deficit we
heard Jonah mentioning it there whereby
they feel Europe has too much of a say
in Northern Ireland's rules and laws
they want to also make sure that
Northern Ireland's place within the
United Kingdom is indivisible that there
is there are no special terms really it
hasn't weakened that bond that they
cherish so much between Northern Ireland
and the UK Mainland and also if they can
get rid of as much oversight from the
European court of justice as they can
then that will be a win for the dup as
well so yeah they're going to be going
through it they're not going to be
coming back to storm they say they're
not going to be resurrecting power
sharing here until they're happy with
the deal so that's what the politicians
want Rory what about the people of
Northern Ireland
well that is a good question because the
issue of the Northern Ireland protocol
is much more important to the
politicians than it seems to be to the
population at large here I've been here
uh for a few weeks on the Trot and
speaking to businesses speaking to
people asking them what they think and
by and large businesses are quite happy
with the protocol actually if you're in
manufacturing it gives you a good uh
basis for doing business because you can
trade with the Republic of Ireland with
the EU and you can trade with the UK
Mainland it gives you actually an
advantage there are issues with it if
you're importing goods and things like
that so I spoke to people running fruit
and vegetable businesses to say yes they
have phytosanitary certificates and
things like that all the kind of boring
bureaucracy that's been increased but
they've found ways around it so if you
ask people yes most I think a small slim
majority uh say that they think that the
protocol is actually working what they
want most of all is for this place to be
back up and running because it's that
it's the provision of services it's
Health it's education those are foremost
in the minds of most people in Northern
Ireland not necessarily the protocol but
of course to get this place up and
running you have to make the dup
satisfied and that is the big question
are they going to be we're going to have
to wait and see absolutely and we will
indeed Rory challenge brings the latest
there from Belfast thanks very much for
the moment